- Are you good at negotiating your salary?
So for myself, I do know
that this is a topic
that is not coming easy to me.
And indeed I launched a
survey on my Instagram channel
Firm Learning and a big
majority of you confirmed
that you are saying
that no, you do not feel
like you are especially great
at negotiating your salary.
Salary negotiation is the topic
that we are going to talk about today.
Welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel Firm Learning.
My name is high Megan. On my
channel I want to help you
to become successful in the
first years of your career.
To provide you the very
best insights on this topic,
I partnered with a good
friend of mine for this video,
and this is Jens.
I met Jens at McKinsey
in the Munich office.
He's also a former McKinsey consultant
later he transitioned to Amazon and worked
there as a buyer for several years.
And now he recently co-founded
a health tech startup.
So we're going to take this
now in the following way
First Jens Will talk a bit
about why it's so important
to regularly negotiate your salary.
Then second, I will talk about
specifically salary raises.
So what you can do if
you're already in a job
and then wanna increase your salary
within your current role.
And then lastly Jens
will share some thoughts
on value creation, on how
you can jointly create value
with your employer in
a salary negotiation.
But the best thing is
that Yens and I recreated
a full online course
on salary negotiation.
The videos that you're now
seeing are just little snippets,
little excerpts of the whole course.
So if this topic interests you
and you'd like to see more from us on it
check out the link to this new course
in the video description.
The course launch this week
so it really is brand
new and we are very much
looking forward to what
you think about it.
So now without further
ado, let's jump into it.
- The importance of salary
negotiation is really
underestimated by most people.
In this video we're going
to show you exactly why
it is so important to consistently
negotiate your salary.
First of all, it really matters
for your lifetime earnings.
It makes a huge difference.
And research has shown
that people who consistently
negotiate their salary
over their entire lifetime
earn about $1 million more
throughout their entire career.
Let's start with getting more.
I want to show you a
simple theoretical graph
that illustrates how
salary negotiations really
impact your salary and how
it increases your earnings
over your entire lifetime.
In this case example
we have two fictional people, Christian
who does not negotiate a salary.
So for him, I assumed
a 1% increase basically
in line with inflation over each year.
On the other hand, there's Theodor
he negotiates his salary every three years
and he is she a 5% average
negotiation success
which is really in line
with what you can expect.
By the end of his career,
Theodore will earn about
$140,000 each year.
While Christian will be
stuck at roughly 80,000.
So this is already a huge difference.
If you add up all the years
where Theodore earns more
and more money than Christian
throughout that entire career,
the difference is enormous.
In this case example,
it's about $1.2 million.
I've oversimplified this, obviously,
but it really proves the
point how important it is
to not be afraid of negotiating a salary.
Usually your employer
will respect you more
If you ask what you are worth.
- So the one thing is to
freshly negotiate your salary
once you get a new job.
But the other thing is once
you're already in the job
then also to be able to
negotiate regular raises.
And this is the topic
that we are going to talk
about in this section.
In this first lecture
I wanna talk about what is realistic?
What can you ask for a raise?
Because this is indeed the
question that I get most
frequently when I discuss this topic
with friends and colleagues.
and hear it all from the head
So really help you with some data.
So in this lecture, I want to help you
by providing a little orientation,
some points of data that might help you
to guide this discussion.
And the first thing to
be aware of is of course
the inflation rate measured
by the consumer price index.
This measures how much prices increase
on average for the
consumer every single year.
Of course these venues differ
significantly country by country.
So you should take this
into consideration depending
on your geography that you work in.
So putting some data for Germany
you can see here that the
values pretty much fluctuate
between one and 2% per year.
And this is exactly the average
that you can expect for
most developed countries.
So one to 2% per year, annual
consumer price inflation.
So make sure to research
this value for your country.
The index might be called a bit different
there might be different
indices, measuring concepts
like this as well for your country.
So look it up in a second.
Similar index that might be helpful here
is the labor cost index.
The choice you'll have much on average
the price for labor.
So the salaries in the country
have gone up over time.
And often these values are more
or less similar in some countries.
The one might be higher than
the other, but here again
if on average salaries
go up by 2% every year
this is where it can give
you a certain indication
of what you should target.
Then, of course you
should not really be happy
with just getting a salary
on the level of inflation.
Because if you exactly
meet the inflation number
you do not really have a salary increase.
And just the fact that
now you can buy next year
as much things with
your money as last year.
Or to put it differently,
If you're not even managed
to get a salary raise
that meets inflation, you
will lose purchasing power.
You pretty much lose value
off your money year on year.
And for these reasons,
compensation for inflation
should pretty much be the minimum
the minimum amount that you ask for
and that you get when you
go into these conversations.
So if this is the one end of the spectrum,
then what is the other
end of the spectrum?
And just to give you
a ballpark figure here
one number that you can expect to receive
if you work in a so-called
accelerated career environment
such as consulting or
banking, is roughly an average
of a salary increase of 10% per year.
So I'd argue that there are
only very very few careers,
very, very few roads that you can get
a longterm average salary increase
of more than 10% per year.
So aim for this 10% in
these very high pace
accelerated career environments.
Of course, there's a reason
that these people get this type of money
of course and these jobs
often need to work a lot.
The performance pressure on
you is quite significant.
So if you are out in a more generous stand
at nine to five corporate job,
probably this is a battalion
should be then adjusted
to a bit of a lower number.
So one to 2%, this is the
minimum that you should get.
This is all such what
some companies provide
just by themselves as a
yearly inflation compensation
to the employees.
And then on top of that you should to ask
for an increase that is up to 10%
based on the type of
career that you're in.
And of course here, the
importance is also to see this
as a longterm average.
So it's absolutely okay to maybe one year
not get that much of a raise.
If then after two years
or after three years,
you get an even higher salary increase
maybe if you step up to
the next higher position.
But make sure that on average,
these are the targets
that you can achieve.
- Welcome to this section
in which we will talk
about how to increase
the overall value for
both sides on the table.
This concept is called value
creation and negotiations.
And it's a very important concept
that you can also apply
to salary negotiations.
So far we've really simplified
the salary negotiation
and only talked about your
total compensation as $1 figure.
But actually there are many
many different elements
that make up your total compensation
and you can make leverage use
of these different
elements to create value
in the negotiation.
It is really a common trap
or mistake people make
in salary negotiations
because they simplify the
many different elements
into $1 figure and this
way they go heads on
with their employer instead
of thinking about clever
and nuanced ways to create value.
The key insight here is the following.
You should aim to negotiate
for salary components
that are worth more to you
and worth less to your employer.
By this way you can
basically create value.
This will enable you to grow
your total compensation by a lot.
Your employer might be bound
by certain salary bands
that are very specific to your role.
And maybe you just barely
missed the qualification
for a more senior role
and it would also have a
different salary range of course.
In this case you can try to negotiate
for a much faster review
of your current role and your promotion.
This gives you a much faster
runway to the next promotion
and therefore a much faster
access to a higher salary.
Another example would be maybe you want
a different job title because you know
that if you switch jobs
it will give you a much
better salary range.
This will actually cost your
current employer nothing.
If they can defend it against
other employees, of course.
But it could be worth a lot to you.
To give you some ideas
of salary components
that you can negotiate
for and that other people
have negotiated for, I will
now show you a brief overview.
Besides the overall component, of course,
your annual cash compensation,
you can negotiate for vacation days.
You can negotiate for a sign on bonus
in case you are switching
to a new employer.
Other common types of
compensation components
can be your relocation coverage.
It could be a tuition
allowance, your job title
as we discussed in the previous example.
It could be the early review.
It could be a company card
or maybe a mobility budget
or in case of particular
smaller companies or startups,
maybe you can negotiate for a visa package
or an equity option package
that gives you a really strong
incentive in the long run
to stay with the company
which is also of course,
interesting to your employer.
You can really extend this
list to many other elements.
I've shown some here on this slide.
Maybe if you already
are a father or a mother
you can negotiate for childcare
support, a parental leave,
or maybe for other people
awareness or fitness program.
Just look through all the components
I'm showing you here on
this slide and get creative.
You will find that by
opening new opportunities
for your employer to compensate
you in some sort of way
be it money monetary or
in case of job titles
giving you future possibilities
and future options,
you can really create a lot of value
for yourself in the negotiation.
As you're preparing for
your next negotiation,
write down the different salary components
that would be relevant
for your negotiation now.
- We hope that you've got
value out of this video
and if it is the case,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe
to my channel to stay up
to date and all my content.
If you want to continue
your learning journey
with Firm Learning, I will link above here
a video on problem solving.
Really one of the key
concerting writing skills.
Check it out to continue learning.
And if you like the topic
of salary negotiation,
please again, check out the link
to the full course that we created
on this topic in the video description.
If you want to see more
from me also follow me
on my Instagram my handle is Firmlearning
or sign up to the mailing list,
link in the video description.
And I'll also wanna say thank you
to all the members of Firm Learning.
Your support is very much appreciated
and check out the join button
If you are interested to
become a member as well.
This is highly from Firm Learning.
I'm releasing new videos
every single Saturday.
So stay tuned for next Saturday.
Happy Easter to all of you.